et j'emmerde tous les pouvoirs d'où
qu'il soit quelle que soit leurs
idéologies et j'emmerde en même temps
ceux qui croient que c'est facile de le
faire parce qu'ils ont qu'à venir le
faire à ma place
Daniel Balavoine sur le Liban sur le
Liban et sur la guerre d'abord tout de
suite nous préciser que vous êtes
concerné directement parce qu'il veut
pas se faire pleurer dans les chaumières
mais je veux dire qu'on parlait tout à
l'heure des adultes qui ne vont pas au
manifestations pacifices et je crois
qu'il y a une juste raison à ça c'est
qu'ils ont eu leur guerre et qui croient
que nous n'en avons pas on entend
souvent dire les adultes oui ça se voit
que vous n'avez pas connu la guerre il
vous faudra une bonne guerre bah je leur
dis maintenant bien en face on l'a la
guerre ma mère a connu trois guerres
finalement puisqu'elle est née pendant
la première elle a eu la deuxième guerre
mondiale et ce matin elle a eu la guerre
la vraie puisque mon frère est au Liban
et ma mère à 7h du matin a su qui avait
des soldats là-bas qui était mort bon
elle ne savait pas sur qui c'était tombé
et jusqu'à midi elle s'est mordu tous
les sens pour savoir si mon frère était
dans le tas ou pas alors je voudrais
dire devant tout le monde que j'emmerde
les anciens combattants que j'en ai rien
à de tout ça qu'on a autre chose
à que de s'occuper des anciennes
guerres qu'on a plus le temps de
manifester pour ça et que les jours des
commémorations qu'il y a pour les
anciennes guerres ont fait mieux ces
jours-là de manifester pour les guerres
qui est actuellement et que tout ça si
je pouvais si mon frère pouvait
m'entendre je lui dire je dirais de
revenir parce qu'on lui dit qu'il va
là-bas pour la paix et ça ce sont des
mensonges j'y vais là-bas pour les
des pouvoirs qui ont créé les
guerres ou qu'elles soient pour des
idéologies et des religions et que tout
ça c'est de la saloperie alors si mon
frère menteur je dis qu'il se laisse pas
berner qui ne croit pas une seconde
qu'il est là-bas pour la paix il est
là-bas pour utiliser des armes pour
faire le commerce et l'industrie des
armes il est là-bas pour défendre les
idées des Russes ou des américains selon
le camp dans lequel on se trouve et des
Syriens et des Palestiniens et que tout
ça c'est de la merde il faut le dire
maintenant aux gens il faut qu'on nous
change la vie on voudrait apprendre à
nos enfants autre chose que ce qu'on
nous a appris et maintenant je le dis
tout effort et tout en emmerdant ce qui
croit que j'ai les idées courtes parce
qu'on peut me donner des heures
d'émissions et si on veut des idées j'en
donnerai et sur un peu tout et je suis
prêt à recevoir sur tous celle des
autres pour montrer s'ils en ont autant
que moi alors je dis que tout ça suffit
qu'il nous faut la paix qu'on veut la
vraie paix et qu'on veut que tous ces
gens-là s'en aille et qu'on arrête de
nous faire croire que tout se passe
entre le socialisme et le capitalisme il
y a eu 15 il y a eu Marx il y aura
d'autres philosophes il y en a eu avant
il y en aura après il y aura d'autres
choses qui se passeront tout ça moi je
le dis je le pense sincèrement c'est de
la merde et on en veut plus et j'emmerde
tous les pouvoirs d'où qu'il soit quelle
que soit leurs idéologies et j'emmerde
en même temps ceux qui croient que c'est
facile de le faire parce qu'ils ont qu'à
venir le faire à ma place voilà
[Musique]